ben cotta
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mio libro storie paurose a scuola di
misteri e ora disponibile in libreria e
online metti alla prova il tuo coraggio
leggilo e accumula tutti i punti della
challenge nel libro
[Musica]
bongiorno come va
buongiorno cosa bene
insomma mi g depositato bene e tu come
dormito io benissimo merlino ciao
berlino ma tu che ci fai qui che fate
voi qui perché stava dormendo tutti qua
non ci ricordi quello che è successo
ieri ma stai scherzando non minimo rete
che cosa è successo
l'ex io ho sognato tutto lo ricordi vero
certo che me lo ricordo tu ti sei
trasformate in un lupo mannaro e
gigantesche ri così grande non puoi
crederci non mi crede scia di tutti
belli più di me guarda guarda guarda le
vecchi guarda e di questi ben ditto ci
vedeva così non sa di cosa state
parlando fatevi dormire un po mi sento
un po stanca in effetti mi sento come se
non avessi dormito tutta la notte
ciao berlino
ma che fai questo non è il momento di
dormire unità sveglia sveglia forza
ma guarda che tu ieri eri al lupo
mannaro e succederà di nuovo ne sono
sicuro e veronese no non mi trasformerò
di noi lohan a roman deve più succedere
questo non deve più succedere ciarlo
adesso devi assolutamente catturare il
lupo deve assolutamente catturarlo il
libro ci vuole libro e qui eccolo ok
allora leggi metti una scheda creatura
smette ecco la scheda gratuita in
effetti sì mi ricorda qualcosa il libro
il libro storie paurose le stele
creatura dobbiamo catturare lo bossi
però non mi ricordo di essere diventata
un lupo mannaro vabbè comunque dies
vediamo se devo sapere il lungo allora
presto messo l'unica soluzione è
catturare il lupo un'asta andata la
trovate dobbiamo catturare il lupo in
bocca al lupo
ho chiamato non emesse ma busto andiamo
da sbrigare aspettiamo mezzo però nella
scheda creatura c'era scritto il punto
debole del lupo mannaro el'argento
dobbiamo prima attrezzarci con qualcosa
di urgente altrimenti ci spronerà e cioè
ci porterà il nuovo avente come aveva
morso ma potresti diventare anche dono
come un oro tratto cerchiamo guardate
d'argento no no no io non voglio
diventare lupo mannaro
cosa possiamo trovarvi argento non lo so
pensiamoci per avere l'argento formale
anche a me quindi io lo devo fare qua
chiesto qua ho cambiato rimani quale ok
ok andremo noi andremo noi sì se sembra
diano cucina sentiamo guardando voce
milano ci avevo pensato andiamo in
cucina porta in bocca al lupo ma lo
sapete in bocca quali lupo
[Risate]
chi è rimasto nascosto
vediamo
andiamo
a voi questi sono bar detto di metallo
per leginio morgando verdetto
probabilmente si sa qualcosa d'argento
però non c'è tempo da perdere ci
dobbiamo preparare adesso vediamo se
però
questo musi come scudo metti così però
sono scudo questo qui non è detto però
sicuramente ti aiuterà nel caso in cui
nel caso in cui un e volesse forlan di
testa
sbaglia totalmente padelle a competere a
un vero al lupo sì qualcosa d argento ci
sarà lo prenderemo no quando male ci
riusciremo a prendere il lupo a
catturare il lupo del libro che vede il
libro
tu il libro non l'hai presa tu dovevo
prendere io metto un mento è rimasto in
casa facciamo pro domo ma si incamera
connesso
c'è un problema ci siamo divertiti un
momento e devo togliere questo
scolapasta dalla testa e allora e
abbiamo preso le cose d'argento ma non
ti preoccupare non ci avvicineremo te
per non farti del male ma per il nostro
attenta state attenti con quelle cose lì
potete farmi del male lo sapete potete
farmi male
brilla troppo un argento brilla brilla
troppo non avvicinatevi comunque no no
guarda li appoggiamo subito qua se serve
solo se volare siamo solo tornati perché
come dire mi sono dimenticato il libro e
avremo bisogno del libro per prendere la
creatura giusto si si lo sono come
facciamo a trovare il lupo è soprattutto
a catturarlo
promesso e qui era quasi sembra forse no
forse lo avevo appoggiato qua non c'è
qua heyneckes tutta cavolo hai visto il
libro libro il libro fetta quale libro
perfetto di quale libro stiamo parlando
dove male come ricordare
come pure libro il mio libro storie
paurose libro viente alle schede
creature hai visto cosa perché parte da
quella foto qua in camera non ci sembra
un po strano un po smemorato forza e
l'ex ci stai forse nascondendo qualcosa
è impossibile che ti sei dimenticato del
libro in libro il vostro libro spettiva
aveva
[Applauso]
celebrato non ti potevi neanche
avvicinato il libro
va bene mi avete smascherato
il libro l'ho preso io e non valori darò
questo è l'unico modo per essere sicuro
di non cadere di nuovo qui dentro è
troppo prezioso è troppo potente anche
per sbaglio voi mi potreste ricatturare
questo non deve succedere non si vuole
aiutare davvero allora l'ex non è buono
come pensavamo e cattivo in realtà non
vuole più a ridarci il libro qui non si
tratta più di amicizia tra loup o lupo
prendi
i morti tutti
[Applauso]
ci siamo nascosti qua sotto
l'ex tassista cercato ma noi siamo
nascosti b lo abbiamo lo portate
d'argento che
consenta il libro non so come fare è che
reca lo farei scusi farai scoprire se
pecoraro pure tu che stai facendo rumore
velo corto è arrivato non li non forzino
guardia lui ci proteggerà con il suo
fiuto da cave
masino fai la guardia ea pisa ci si
arriva all ex il lupo ok
il libro è ora disponibile in tutte le
librerie sono quindi potremo andare i
primi a prenderne un'altra cosa io tremo
catturare l'ex il lupo è anche le altre
creature aspetta se andiamo in libreria
dobbiamo lasciare berlino da solo qui
con le creature con l'ex non possiamo
mai lasciarlo da solo
ma non arriverebbe subito quindi non
possiamo prenderlo suona tanto abbiamo
per portar devo per forza riprendere
quella coppia di pallina voi l'avete
preso invece avete preso il libro storie
paurose se non l'avete ancora preso è
ora disponibile in tutte le librerie
online non mi ricordo pero ei
i brutali
giochiamo vi sia per il nostro e adesso
io mi trovo e adesso non trovo quindi vi
siete nascosti e del
mondo vi troverò io vi mostrerò
mirino vi voglio aiutare tu mi puoi dire
per favore sono anni di vita lì
non mi vuoi aiutare
il tono tranquillo lo vedevo ma che
tranquillo tranquillo perché no no no no
no ma
forse dio lo sa bene che troverò io
rimanderò
porta cercando di convincere berlino
aderito per te amore tutti a berlino
bravissimo non è quindi la niente ci
proteggerà
berlino si sta arrabbiando non a mandare
via l'extra il lupo perché ha capito che
è cattivo sì penso che dobbiamo
approfittarne di questo momento e salire
sopra nascondersi e vero si berlino ci
sta coprendo le spalle scopriamo adesso
tanto vi il lupo non farò mai del male a
merlino perché è un cane come se il
tranquillo va bene
sempre in
questo cane non vuole aiutare berlino
non è collaborativo eppure pensavo fossi
amici sa io ti voglio bene ma tu almeno
mi vuoi così bene
presto presto presto grosso dove ce ne
facciamo trascina studiamo lo so magari
non proprio qui sta arrivando st rivaldo
l'ex il lupo dobbiamo trovare uno
spuntino subito per loro l'idea che
permettiamo delle trappole come lui
crederà che siamo nascosti qua in camera
ma in realtà siamo nascosti da un'altra
parte e scegliamo un altro nascondiglio
così lui perderà tempo e noi potremmo
trovare un nascondiglio migliore
l'importante è che riprendiamo il libro
così potremo farlo al lupo si no ha
un'idea prenderò le mie pantofole che
bene vedo rombo carini tesi rytas
pregate non ha detto qua così così mette
il contrario
ecco fatto e di lui allora crederà che
non ascolta dietro la tenda io invece ho
lasciato qui una manica di fuori così
penserà che sono nascosto ha detto
proverà a cercarmi scattiamo adesso però
da un'idea
così potremmo dire di un passo dai testa
un'idea che però se gli tirò siamo tutti
i pupazzi interna chandor dirlo magari
riuscirebbe a stordirlo e riusciremo poi
a rubargli il libro anzi posso tirare
anche l'aeroplano
[Musica]
i pupazzi
dove siete unità d'italia dove siete
dovete giocare
volete giu ci sta cercando a
[Musica]
nessuno ciao berlino vuol dire dove
siamo
numero di per me timbro
non vuoi collaborare ma bene va bene va
bene allora la città inserì sopra eletto
dai venite fuori
io voglio soltanto morte e
giocare con voi
è caduto non abbiate
no
sono proprio furbi ciao a prendere il
libro forse dobbiamo iniziare ad
attaccarlo con i bubba altresì altre lo
attacchiamo
una
[Musica]
fuga che ci sono
1 si sta rialzando dobbiamo tirare
qualcosa d'argento
dove cercarlo certo certo c'è chi si
programmino è così il libro ma presto
dobbiamo subito andare a catturare
l'altro lupo sia un po ci occuperemo di
lex ma tanto mi sembra che berlino lo
stato nel tuo padre presto facciamoci
guidare verso il lupo si
no guardia ala guardia ex
e dietro questa sia per contro l'uomo
allontanamento
vogliamo solo
sì c'è un fatto ha catturato aggiunto
più tornare da lei si mangia un frutto
abbiamo catturato il lupo ora manchi
solo tu fattori dove un libro no vi
prego vi prego 1 fatelo dobbiamo per
forza catturarti pensavamo fatti quando
finì 6 tradito rubato ci si proprio non
volevo io non volevo solo che abbiamo
paura di tornare in quel libro ho fatto
tutto per questo non ti credo al mio 3
aprile il libro e tornerai dentro il
libro
per favore per favore ti prego vi
scongiuro di 297 vie propri ragazzi per
piacere possiamo ancora essere amici
anzi facciamo così facciamo un patto
siete pronti facciamo un patto con cui
dovremo fidarsi di lex se poi mi
lasciate libero io voglio però trovare
l'altra creatura beh in effetti potrebbe
esserci utile altrimenti come facciamo
ad affrontare da soli ci servirebbero
dei consigli anche se abbiamo già le
schede creatura nel pd non ci serve
troppo aiuto perché abbiamo le schede
creatura no per favore per favore fatelo
per me ma non solo vi aiuterò con la
creatura ma ogni volta che avrete
bisogno potrete chiamarmi e io verrò da
voi ad aiutarvi ora vi spiego come è
bene che domenica potrebbe essere
trafitto una l'elenco che allora per
potermi chiamare dovete bussare nel
libro tre volte e poi fare e
così io arriverò da voi oppure ma questo
solo se sarete veramente in pericolo ma
veramente in pericolo dovete fare così
a me sembra che ci stia preme leggero
quindi sto dicendo che se siamo in reale
pericolo ci basterà solo un mare ok non
ci credete provate a fare quanto appena
detto però guarda è ok ma questo prezzo
come
oltre
123 e movimento noi a bahia
ha detto da dove apparso nei trattati
magico libro magico
sembra di sì quindi forse è va bene mi
sembra che ti sei pentito di quello che
ho fatto è che l'hai fatto solamente
perché avevi paura di essere rinchiuso
nel libro quindi siccome ci darà il tuo
aiuto ogni volta che lo vorremmo affare
fatto benissimo benissimo saremo un
grande team insieme ok ma vi raccomando
non tradirci più provetto progetto non
succederà mai più non sono pentito dico
davvero aspettiamo meglio non ho
controllato se è apparsa la scheda
creatura controlla vediamo allontanatisi
la scheda creatura e completa one sarà
la prossima creatura attenti la prossima
creatura è molto molto molto più
pericolosa del lupo mannaro che avete
sfilato adesso ma sapete io avrei da
fare a chiamarti mix avrete bisogno di
aiuto ok ciao ciao ciao l'ex e mi
raccomando lasciate un mi piace per
vedere il prossimo episodio di storie
paurose e se non avete ancora preso il
libro è ora disponibile in tutte le
librerie online non potete non averlo
all'interno troverete già tutte le
schede creatura le catene linking
descrizione per prenderlo subito
[Musica]